magnifique initiative pour
l'homoparentalité la transparentalité
c'est génial tout le monde a le droit
d'être enceinte ou enceinte tout le
monde a le droit d'être père je trouve
ça formidable ils ont été critiqués mais
globalement il marqueront l'histoire par
cette innovation je leur dis bravo 1000
bravo moi je mettrai juste un petit
bémol sur les intentions parce que je
moi je trouve ça super bien évidemment
pour la visibilité des personnes LGBT
des personnes trans celles qui sont
enceintes peu importe mais je me demande
dans quelle démarche glamour a fait ça
est-ce que c'est pour du buzz parce
qu'ils savent très bien qu'il va avoir
énormément de commentaires notamment des
commentaires extrêmement négatifs qui ne
vont pas nécessairement faire avancer
avancer la cause ou est-ce qu'ils l'ont
fait dans une optique de défaire évoluer
les mentalités j'ai un doute je j'ai
peur du bad buzz aussi honnête si on est
honnête peu importe peu importe ce que
ça va générer parce que c'est le mois
c'est le mois des fiertés donc ils l'ont
ils ont utilisé ce mois des fierté pour
justement poser le débat et après tout
on a le droit justement de de faire
que les personnes trans ne soient plus
invisibilisées là on les met en lumière
en couverture après libre à nous
justement de façon dépassionnée dans des
barres etc tu vois je trouve que c'est
elle est complètement démagogique cette
une c'est pour surfer sur une mode c'est
la réalité
du buzz pas de la mode c'est nier la
réalité un homme ne peut pas tomber
enceinte déjà parce que non mais oui
les hommes en seins il y en a quasiment
pas et je pense que le message est
mauvais et c'est ce qu'ils font ça
moi je vous dis la vérité l'année
dernière j'avais un pote à la maison il
est temps un moment autour de la piscine
j'ai cru qu'il allait accoucher
[Applaudissements]
pour faire du buzz mais c'est encore une
fois la réalité un homme ne peut pas
être enceinte
tu dis que tu es d'accord avec moi on
n'est pas d'accord parce que j'ai dit
déjà premièrement un homme peut être
enceinte puisque c'est officiellement un
homme et nous il est enceinte donc
un homme ne peut pas être enceinte sur
sa pièce d'identité c'est un homme
mais sinon la transition
si il a voulu c'était une femme il a
voulu être un homme qui reste un homme
pourquoi il veut accoucher maintenant
pourquoi il veut redevenir
mais moi je te rejoins toi je pense que
le bad buzz il va plus arriver en
faisant ça que le truc bien on a qu'à
voir les commentaires
la démarche de ce monsieur c'est que il
a notamment fait un blog etc parce qu'il
veut raconter son cheminement raconter
les les tourments par les calipasses
pour que justement ce soit accessible à
tout le monde que ça soit plus un
fantasme que chacun projette pas des
idées etc et connaissent la réalité de
sa vie oui
merci Hugo c'est que tu dis en gros je
ne sais pas s'ils ont fait ça pour le
buzz pour en faire parler parce qu'il se
prend leurs intentions mais en fait
est-ce que toi tu as vu les les
commentaires que tu as rien qui est on
en parle moi je le sais et j'ai vu les
commentaires là-dessus
mais parlons de la transphobie parlons
de l'homophobie aujourd'hui dans la
société au contraire donc sous prétexte
il y a des gens qui sont homophobe se
transforme on va vous invisibiliser
et faire une une qui pourrait paraître
provocatrice à une époque où les où ça
pose problème à certains nombre de
personnes et qui va avoir énormément de
commentaires négatifs parce que en fait
ce genre de une ça ne va pas les gens
vont dire ah quand même vraiment avec
cette une ah j'étais transforme et
maintenant je vais plus être
malheureusement ça se passe pas il y
avait des homosexuels sur les plateaux
avant de regarder comme des pestiférés
donc tu trouves pas que c'est quand même
une bonne évolution je suis désolé en
fait genre moi j'ai toujours défendu les
trans donc je ne sais pas oui non mais
je sais mais c'est pour ça que peu
importe en fait c'est pour ça que
Valérie a raison peu importe le bad buzz
parce qu'il y aura toujours
une couverture et d'ailleurs je l'aime
bien cette couverture c'est juste que là
c'est un homme enceinte c'est c'est
niche on a eu combien il a eu quelques
quelques dizaines sur la planète et
juste dernière petite chose après je
vais parce que je parle beaucoup mais
souvenez-vous il y a quelques années
dans Secret Story Thomas c'était encore
les quelques années et ben la transe
phobie était j'ai l'impression était
était moins forte qu'aujourd'hui et ça
m'inquiète parce que à l'époque il est
quand même arrivé deuxième de la saison
les gens voter pour lui alors c'était un
homme trans qui était hermaphrodite
de dire des conneries
c'est bon
c'est bon là le débat s'il vous plaît ah
oui bah voilà est-ce que c'est est-ce
que c'est une bonne chose non à 90 %,
merci les téléspectateurs apparemment
ils n'ont pas aimé cette une voilà donc
voilà donc merci d'avoir répondu après
avoir dépendu merci à vous d'avoir fait
le débat pour ça qu'on est Guillaume ça
n'a rien à voir donc soutenir à fond
mais pas du tout non plus
on peut dire la vérité et de ce qu'on
pense désolé on dit c'est une mode voilà
ça leur voilà
moi je pense que c'est comme un Hugo
c'est Hugo il aime pas il aime pas qu'on
serve de ça pour faire du beurre
c'est pour faire du bad buzz et quand et
j'ai pas je n'aime pas comme ça dessert
et je me pose la question sur le sursis
sur cette une la particularité
mais là homme enceinte c'est tellement
rare et niche même si je leur souhaite
tout le bonheur du monde bien évidemment
que je me pose la question de l'intérêt
pour la communauté mais non c'est pas
une question il y a plein d'autres
façons les montages j'ai justement donné
l'exemple il y a quelques années Secret
Story le mec qui est arrivé deuxième